And we're back. What's the answer, Michael?
>> Okay, so it depends.
>> What does it depend on?
I've given you everything. This is straightforward.
>> Well, so, okay, I guess. The here, so here's what I'm seeing.
So I'm, what I'm seeing is that hypothesis one is the most likely hypothesis.
>> It's not just the most likely, it's the most a posteriori.
>> Well, that's what I mean by likely.
Right, is the map hypothesis? It's the maximum a
posteriori hypothesis. So if we say, what is the
label according to the map hypothesis? Boom, it's plus.
>> Yes.
>> But, if we're saying what's the
most likely label. So the most likely label
is, is, we have to actually look over all the hypotheses and in a sense,
let them vote. So the probability that the label is minus is actually 0.6, which
is greater than 0.4, so if I had to pick, I would go with minus.
>> And you would be correct. So I did a
little tricky thing here for you Michael. You've been complaining about
my titles, because everyone said Bayesian learning and
I changed the title here to Bayesian Classification.
>> Ohhh.
>> Because in fact the problem here, we've been talking about all along
is, what's the best hypothesis. But here. I ask you what's the best label?
>> Hm. And exactly as you point out, finding the
best hypothesis is a, is a very simple algorithm. Here I'll
write it for you because we did it before. For
every H in hypothesis set, simply compute the probability that it
is the best one, and then simply output max. That's how you find the best
hypothesis, but that's not how you find the best label. The way you find the
best label is you basically do a
weighted vote for every single hypothesis in the
hypothesis set, according to the weight being
the probability of that hypothesis given the data.
>> Okay.
>> So the best, if you can only output hypothesis and use that hypothesis,
in fact, you would say plus. But if you asked everyone
to vote, just like we did with boosting, just like we
did effectively with KNN and all these other kind of. Weighted
regression techniques we've used before, you need to do the voting.
>> And I, and I feel like I could probably derive
that using rules of probability. Right, because really what we want is
we're trying to maximize the probability of the label, given the
data, and I think the probability laws would tell us that's equal
to the sum over all hypotheses of the hypothesis and the
label given the data, which is, like, the probability of the
hypothesis given the data, times the probability of the label
given the hypothesis, and that's what we did, we summed up.
You know, the probability of the label given the hypothesis
is either one or zero. That's your left column. And then
we're summing up the probabilities that corresponding to the pluses. And
we're summing up the probabilities corresponding to the minuses and choosing
the largest one.
>> So, this is what you just said written down
as an equation. basically, the most likely value. Is the
one that maximizes this expression. And this follows directly from
Bayesian's rule where now instead of trying to maximize the
hypothesis given the data, you're trying to maximize the value
given the data. And I think it's pretty straightforward to
derive that but I'd like to leave it up to
the students to do it on their own. Okay, so Michael,
in some sense everything that I've told you before is a
lie, in that I've led you down this path that somehow,
finding the best hypothesis is the right thing to do. But
the truth is, finding the value is what we actually care about.
Finding a hypothesis is just a means to an end. And
if we have a way of actually computing the probabilities for
all the hypotheses, then we should let them to vote in order
to find the best actual label or the best value for it.
>> Got it.
>> All right. Good.